ladies and gentlemen the 45th and final
President of the United States thank you
thank you I'm so proud of what we've
accomplished today
everyone loved when Obama killed bin
Laden and now everyone will remember
where they were when I freed OJ Simpson
mr. president mr. president your party
controls the whole government
why can't you pass a health care bill it
would have passed if it weren't for the
3 to 5 million illegal senators who
shouldn't have been able to vote in the
first place so is your plan now just to
kill Obamacare I'm not killing Obamacare
I'm letting it die naturally
the same way you let your grandmother
die naturally by unplugging your oxygen
and shoving her down the stairs
is there a theme tonight tonight steam
is made in America because what makes
America great is what America makes Wow
that's like the first good thing I've
ever said we're celebrating the
hardworking Americans who are making all
kinds of things from the lady in the
shower cap who makes honey bunches of
oats to the elves and the 3/4 fudge all
the stripes and of course those
beautiful Clydesdale horses the love
beer and hate 911 all such great
American why did you say it was unfair
for Jeff Sessions to recuse himself on
Russia I have a very simple test for
fairness does this thing earn me money
make me look smart or aroused me
sexually if the answer to any of those
is no totally unfair any comments on the
continuing accusations that you colluded
with Russia no I don't have a comment
what do I look like Don Jr I know yes
yeah please John Jr wishes he looked
like this folks let's not make this into
something ugly like my son if I could
get rid of them I would but someone's
got to go to jail I'm the president can
you reveal it nope what's wrong